知る機能によって生命っている
生命って何でしょうかというと
仏教は科学的な定義で知る機能ですと知る機能あれば生命です
すごく単純で簡単です
で じゃあ中身に入ってみます
これはタイトルで 心の発見
知る機能っていうのは心ですから
自分はこれから心の発見してみましょう
かなり具体的に死体と自分を比較して何が違いますかと発見してください
と それは心の発見する一番簡単な方法なんです
死体と自分を比べる 比べて何が違いますかと
で みんなすごく頭が良い
すごく頭が良さそうなんです
私はこの質問は毎回毎回瞑想すると出しますけど
なかなか誰もわからないんですよ
死体と自分が何が違いますかと
ある方がもう魂がないんだよと
あれ 何言ってるの あんたはと
私は驚きましたけど あんた見たことあるの？と
魂はと 見たこと触ったことあるのかと
そしたらすごく怒られたんです
馬鹿にされたと すごい頭良かったんですね
本人は 死体と自分の差は魂がないことでは
もう本当にもう何回も
このこれを瞑想するところはとても大事なことで
で これは瞑想はすごくスピードアップするために
もう何年も修行で体験しなくちゃいけないことは
私はまあできるだけ10分で
15分でもうすっともう超特急で押してやろうと思って出す質問なんですけど
一応推測して まあそれなりに常識的な知識があるだろうと
びっくりするだけで 私も
死体は家 机 木 土などと全く同じ物体です
死体っていうのは この間
木曜日の瞑想会で物体でしょと言ったら
ある女の子が愛しい人の死体はそんな物体じゃないんだと
もう気持ち悪いものでも何でもないんだと
ああそう でもあんたの死体
人の死体はね 私にとっては物体で大嫌いやと
そうじゃないんでしょうかって
それはそうでしょうと
だから親しいかないか関係なく
死体は物体なんです それは母の死体だからとかね
そんなの関係ないんです
死体は物体です これは家と机と木と
もう壁と全然変わりはないんです
しかし 生きている私は単純に物体だとするのは難しい
私も単純な物体だよと
死体も単純な物体だよというのは
これができないんですよ
私は生きているんだから
そういうわけで具体的に発見しています
で これからは皆様すごく損します
瞑想する人々には初めての質問として出しますから
その時は頭が回転して無明が破れて
分別する知識が生まれますけど
一旦言っちゃうとこれがカットになるんです
よく覚えてください もうよく
私と死体 私は働く 動く
心臓が動く 働く 呼吸している
栄養を取る 体温がある
怪我したら治る まあ朽ちることはない
死体になってくると動きません
心臓は止まっている 呼吸しない
栄養は取らない 栄養を取らない
冷たい 再生しない 腐っていく
バカバカらしく聞こえる
見える 感じるでしょうね
とんでもないことです
これが本当の智慧の世界なんです
本当の科学的に見ると
これなんです 魂がないとか霊魂がないとかね
いい加減なことじゃなくて
そこで一人一人すごく不思議なんでしょうね
例えば 1番目 私はもう動くでしょうに
これが生きてるという証拠でしょう
アメーバを顕微鏡で見たってのは
アメーバが生きてるかないかっていうことは
どうやって知るんですかね
顕微鏡の中で あれ 水の中で動いてるんだったら生きてるんです
全く動けなかったらもうわからない
だから細胞 1個 1個いつでも動いてますよ
だからそれがすごい不思議なことなんです
この動きって何なのかと
それで心臓が まあ私たちには心臓もありますからね
心臓が働いているでしょうに
これにしたっても すべて物理学法則を壊しているでしょうに
これぐらい長い血管に
もう生まれた時からおなかの中から始めて
死ぬまで絶えず血液をポンプするという機械なんかは作れませんよ
機械作っても またまた修理したり
点検したり 部品入れ替えたり
いろいろしなくちゃいけない
これがなくよく もう人間には作れないほど強烈なポンプなんですよ
でも心臓ってただの肉の塊
こんな力あるのかと これにはと
ちょっと駅まで走っただけでもうもう息切れるのに
息が切れるのに だからそれってのはすごいことで
これが生きているということなんです
で 呼吸しているっていうことも
ずっとこの酸素を入れたり
入れて入れて入れて入れていくんですね
で 栄養をとる 栄養をとるっていうことはまた不思議なことで
細胞一個一個 24時間瞬間も止まることなく栄養をとっているんです
もう口で食べることだけじゃないんです
栄養をとるっていうことは
我々は 24時間食べなくちゃいけないんです
だから栄養をとるっていうことは
口で食べることだけではなくて
ずっと細胞にずっと栄養が入っているんです
で これ そういうすごい信じられない機能
細胞には栄養がなくなった途端死んじゃう
だからすごいことですよ
そこで体温もすごいことでしょう
ずっと一定の温度で体の中で熱を作っているんですよ
だから走ったりすると体は暖かくなるんですけど
何もしないでいたっても
ちゃんと体の中でエネルギーは燃えて燃えて
一定の温度で保っているんです
そこで法則の中で この自然の法則と種の法則もありますから
周りが寒くなってくると
もう体がもう一定の温度で保つのは大変だから
いろいろなんとかそれなりに合わせて工夫したりする
そこで死体なんかはもう 35度でずっと 1 日
あるいは 1週間ぐらい保っておこうというと
結構大変な機械が必要になるんですよ
すごくエネルギーかかりますよ
お金がかかりますよ 例えば死体を温めておこうと思って
何か暖かい箱に入れても周り
暖かくなるんですけど
中はどうでしょうかね
中まで熱は通りません
そこで中の細胞まで熱が通ろうとしちゃうと
外の方がすごく ものすごく熱くなっちゃうんです
これってできることじゃないんです
これ自体摩訶不思議でしょうね
我々はそうじゃなくて
もう中も外も全部同じ
それから怪我したら治るということ
これ再生のことなんですけど
自然のものっていうのは
自分で自分を治すっていうことは誰もしませんよ
生命だけ それするのは
自分で自分を治す 処理する
なんで人間そういうことを発見しないんですかね
命ってな 死体と自分は何が違いますかというと
いくらでもあるでしょう
また そういうものは徹底的に研究する必要もないでしょうに
当たり前の事実 この当たり前のことは真剣に考えないんだから
無知になっちゃうんです
物体なんか壊しちゃったら壊したで壊れたで
物体なんかは自然にだいたい壊れて壊れて壊れていくプロセスですよ
生まれて生まれていくということはないんです
地球にしたっても どんどんどんどん壊れていく
太陽にしたっても どんどんどんどん壊れていく
山も川も何でもかんでも壊れていくんです
成長していくということはないんです
壊れて別な形になるだけ
だからある一方的 一方方向で生きているんですよ
生命は違うんですね 我々のは
人間から見れば 人間はもう 25代後までは年まではどんどんどんどん成長して増やしていって
それからあるもう 10年
15年ぐらい一定の状態でいて
それから減っていくんですよ
それでも修復機能はいつでも持っている
怪我したらたちまち細胞がそれ直しちゃうんです
だからこのそれ再生するということをね
大変なことなんですよ
それからまあ だからこそ朽ちないんですね
まあ腐るんだけど 腐ったものを捨てちゃって
新しいものを作ったといって
我々の体っていうのは肉体でしょうね
こんな 35度でいるならば
みるみるうちに腐るはずなんですよ
皆様が買っている肉なんかはずっと冷凍庫でしょ？スーパーに売ってる
あの死んでる肉体は その肉体を買おうといって
いく肉体が腐らないんですね
冷凍庫ではなくて暖房をつけているんですよ
買ってきた肉も暖房ついてる部屋に置いといてください
すぐ腐るんです だから自然法則と違うでしょ
生きている肉体は 自然法則でいえば
こんな暖かい部屋に生肉を置いちゃうと
もう早くも腐って悪臭を出すんですよ
でも我々の肉体はそうじゃないんです
ちょうど腐る年度ですよ
温度ですよ  35 から 40 間っていうのは
どんな肉でもたちまち腐ってしまうね
温度です 80 とか 110 とかね
150 200 になってくると
まあ干し肉になりますけど
でも体っていうのはこの
大変ですよ こういうところはよくリストよく覚えてください
一つ一つものすごい不思議なものなんです
生きているということは
それから私は話す 蹴られたら痛い
反応するんでしょ？見える
聞こえる 味わう 触覚がある
体で感じる 遺体は話さない
転ぶだけで反応しない
遺体蹴っても転ぶかもしれませんだけど
何の反応もないんですね
自分たちを蹴ったら 誰かが
ただでは済みませんね
それで我々には見えるんだけど
遺体の目は反応しない
それはちょこっと ここら辺はこの推測というか
実験しないとわからないんですよ
ここまでのものは その一発でわかる事実です
100%もう確かです
ここから見えるところからは推測働くんです
それで私には見えることは
まあまあ証拠はいらん
しかし 遺体にも目はありますけど
死体にも何を見せても別にどうったことないんですよね
例えばサーチライトみたいに
このスポットライト目に入れたっても全然
そこで自分の目に誰かスポットライト当てちゃうと
もう痛くて涙が出て もう何も見えなくなっちゃってひどい目にあいますよ
だから遺体はもう何目に何を見せても
ヘビを見せても もうすごい格好美しい花を見せても全然反応ないんですよ
だから反応はないっていうことにするしかないんです
耳も同じでしょうに 私たちのはちょこっとあんた何やと言っただけでも腹が立つでしょうに
痛いのは言いたい放題悪口言ってみてください
耳元で反応はないんです
だから聞こえないということは推測できる
だから舌も反応しないし
どんな辛いものも遺体に遺体の舌の上に入れてもね
大丈夫です で それで体も何にも触っても無反応ですね
そこで遺体と死体と私の差がまだリストが出てきたんです
この見えるところまで上は全部一発で知ってることで
ここ下は微妙に調べたらよくわかるんです
むちゃくちゃ推測する必要もないんです
まあ大体リストはこんな程度です
また ちょこちょこっと推測でいくリストはあります
笑ったり怒ったりする
そなたの感情も私にはあります
えーと 眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報について考える
私は目耳鼻から入る情報について考えます
何の音でしょうかとかね
なんか玄関の方に音がして
泥棒でも入ったんでしょうかとかね
と考えたりする 悩んだり落ち込んだり
妄想したりする それで今ではなくて
今の状況で満足できず
環境と自分を変えようとする
私たちはずっとそれやってます
この部屋に入ったら ちょっと寒いんだったら
その状況に満足しないんですね
暖房ないかな 暖房ないかなと
暖房をつけようとするんです
夏場 夏 この部屋に来たらやっぱり暑い
何か冷房ないかなとかね
いつでも環境を変えようとしてるんです
これ 生きるものがやっていることで
犬も猫もミミズも誰でもやってます
環境を変えること 満足しない
死体はそうじゃないんです
まあ冷凍したっても死体はへっちゃらで
それは 冷凍から出して火葬場に持っていって
もうガスで燃やしちゃうでしょう
全然大丈夫です 大体死体はいっぱいおしゃれさせるでしょうに
死体にとってはどうでもいいんです
おしゃれさせたくても
裸にしたっても 我々ですよ
それも我々は環境には満足しない
変えよう変えようとしています
死体は笑ったり怒ったりはしない
わかるのはそれだけなんだよ
死体は笑わない 怒らない
その他の感情もない だろうと推測はできます
だから まあ笑ったり怒ったりしないんだから
嫉妬したりもしないでしょう
死体は だからそれ推測です
確かな情報じゃない 遺体の心臓は動いてないんだぞというぐらいの確かな情報じゃないんです
微妙な推測なんです で
考えないと推測できます
まあよくみんなね この質問を出すと
よくみんな先に言うのは
死体は何も考えていないんだぞと
どうやってあんた知ってるのかと
だからもう推測のことを当たり前のことに言うんですよ
それダメなんですよ 死体は考えてるかないかわかるわけないでしょうね
それは推測なんです だって
眼耳鼻舌身 反応しないでしょ
情報入らないんですね
私は眼耳鼻舌身に入る情報で考えてるんだから
目に何か入ったらこれは何だろうとかね
美しいものでしょうとかね
で 私は考える 目は反応しないんだったら
そこは不可能になるのは当たり前でしょうに
耳に音が入っちゃうと
私はなんて綺麗な音楽でしょうかとかね
それは誰の歌でしょうかとか考えたりする
死体の目は反応しないんだから
そういう考え方はなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから死体は考えないっていうことは推測であって
それも科学的にはちゃんとした推測なんですよ
実際 100%の確率の事実とは言えない
だから考えたりしないんだから
まあどうせ悩み 落ち込み
妄想もないと推測できます
自分を変えよう 環境を変えようとは全くしない
これははっきりわかりますけど
これをこちらで比べて入れたんです
これには証拠は要りませんだけどね
なぜならば 生きているものにとってはこの現状に満足しないという
面白い現象があるんですよ
子供は子供でいいんだけど
それでは子供も満足しないし
親も満足しない もう変えよう変えようとしている
変わってしまったところで
変わらなかった方が良かったとも思ったりもする
で 私と物体という まあ死体は死体という単語は一応物体にしたんです
より普遍的に えーと 物体と私は何が違いますか？という問いに
大雑把に15項目 19
項目の項目を見つかりました
あれ 全部19なんです
リストは だと思う  いい加減に数えたんだから
これは一般的に生きている命ということです
この19のリストっていうのは生きてるっていうことですよ
一般一般的に言えば 別に不可思議な魂は発見した？ないんです
しかし  1個1個摩訶不思議ですよ
この腐れないっていうことは摩訶不思議でしょうに
法則に逆らっているでしょうに
心臓さえも摩訶不思議で法則に逆らっているでしょうに
環境を変えることも 何やこれ
すごい自然法則じゃないでしょうに
だから 1個1個摩訶不思議なんですよ
しかし 神秘的で 霊魂とか魂とか
神様に吹き込まれた呼吸とか何もないんです
仏教的にこれらの働きをすべて心と言えるんです
それで仏教では命 生きている魂
霊魂とか何とかという曖昧非科学的な単語を置いておいて
科学的な単語で心っていうことにしているんです
だからわかりやすく言えば
私には心がある 死体には心がない
ただそれだけ では心って何で言えば言えば
ご飯食べることも心で
栄養をずっと 24時間取ることも心で
あの動きも心なんですよ
細胞一個絶えず動いてます
それも心 呼吸も心 この体温
それも心なんです 心が燃やしてるんです
あの生命の寿命っていうのは体温で決めます
それで我々は外からいろんな酸素も入れて
物質も入れて 細胞の中で燃やしてますよ
燃やしている間は大丈夫です
生き続ける どんどん燃やす力が減っちゃうんです
細胞も疲れちゃうんです
もう燃やせなくなっちゃったと
それでも燃やしますけど
だから我々年取っていくと
食べる量は自然に減っちゃうんです
子供はたくさん食べるんです
いつでも何か食べていて
それでどんどん大きくなってくると
そう いつでも何か食べるっていうことはなくなっちゃって
年取ってくると結構減ってしまいます
なぜかというと もう燃えません
もし燃えないにも関わらず
例えば 40  50代で燃えないにも関わらず
若者みたいに食べちゃうとどうなるのかと
かなり早く火種が消えます
弱い火種でしょうね それに大量に燃料をあげちゃうと消えます
燃えるわけじゃないんです
まあガス ガソリンがあるでしょ
ちょっとしたことで引火してるでしょ
でも試しにやらないでください
あのちょこっとした火種があって
例えばマッチ１つ燃えているとかね
いきなりさっとガソリンかけちゃうと消えます
ゆっくりちょろちょろだったらもう大変なことになりますけどね
その場合はもう燃料入れすぎ
だから体もそういうことで
だから我々はこの体温を保つ力
これは寿命というんですけどね
火種が これは何年持つのかということは大体は決まっている
それに若い時からもういっぱい燃料をあげたら
かなり縮むんです 燃えるぐらい適当に毎日この適当に燃える量しかあげない
だったら寿命はきちんと全うするんです
だからよく仏教の話でね
まあ食べ物の量を知りなさいと
量を知って食べると それで健康になるんだよと
この量って何やというと
この燃える量なんです
あの茶碗 1杯しかご飯食べませんというのは
これも人間 考えている無知な考え方で
茶碗 2杯食べるか 一杯一杯食べるか
半分食べるかっていうことは
そのその個人の燃えるスピードに合わせなくちゃいけないんです
それが適量ということなんです
1 日何 1000 カロリーっていうのは
これは無知な世界で発見するもので
1 日何千千五百二千五百
で 私は 1 日 2500 は取ってないんです
死んじゃう それ取っちゃうともう死んじゃうじゃなくて
すごい苦しいんです だから燃える量に合わせるんです
それが適量ということで
このように具体的に命
心を発見するんです それでは皆様方が具体的に明確に心を発見したことにしてください
心っていうのは 19 の項目なんです
だから心はどこにあるのかどうかね
こんなのありっこはない
ただの脳細胞でしょうとかいうのは科学的な考え方じゃないんです
人間っていうのはすべて脳だけだというのは
これはもう非科学的な科学的な発見なんです
まだ科学は非科学的なんですよ
だから心は脳の細胞の中にもありまして
足にもあります 指先にもあります
どこにでもあります ただ
機能のことですからね
ものじゃありません この理解でかなり瞑想っていうのはぐーんと早くなるんです
このリストをしっかりと覚えておいて
これやとはっきり納得してしておけば
それから今までは大雑把なところになってきたので
これからこのちゃんとした論理的な意味
仏教ではもうしっかり論理的にしないと
以上のリストからわかることは
私は自分の体も その体の
外の世界も認識する 知るということなんです
さらに考えると この肉体が何をやっているんですかね
この物体が この物体が物体
自分のことを知っています
でしょう まず面白いでしょうね
物体は自覚を持っているということは
それで この物体は自分の物体のことを知っているだけではなくて
周りのことも知っている
これが心ということなんです
知るということなんです
で これから仏教でいうヴィンヤーナというヴィンヤーも認識なんですけど
いくつかの単語を逆さま使ってますけどね
で まあ日本語で知るという単語に絞るんです
もうちょっと複雑になったかもしれませんよ
心っていうのは 19 の項目なんですけど
これよくよく見ると この知る機能なんです
例えば細胞に体に栄養が減っちゃうと知るでしょ
あ 栄養足らんだそうとかね
食べなくちゃと思っちゃうでしょうね
お腹がすいたとかね もし熱くなっちゃうと
あ これはダメだ なんとか冷やさなくちゃとわかるでしょ
これが生きているってことでしょう
で 怪我したら まあそのわかる場合もあるし
わからなくてもちゃんと治るんですよ
そちらにも知る機能があるんです
だから結局は心っていうのは知るというそのものです
だからこの単語にもうこれからずっと定着して考えてください
あの一般論からどんどんどんどんどんレベル高い智慧に持っていきますので
で 今日書いてないんだから普通に説明いたします
知るっていうことでは 2つありますよ
例えばお腹がすいて減ったら知る
はっきり知ってますね
で 怪我したらその瞬間では知っている
痛い時だけ それから忘れちゃうんですよ
それで 2日経ってみたら治っていると
でも治っていても細胞はちゃんと知らなきゃダメでしょ
新しい細胞が出てきて
それで傷跡も再生して
皮膚もちゃんと再生して終わったら OK
ストップやと ちゃんとそちら辺で管理なければダメでしょ
そこでこの意識無意識でしたっけ
仏教では無意識っていう単語はないんです
すべて知る世界なんです
ただ 我々の概念の中で
知らないだけで 本当は知ってるということで
だから管理できるのは
お腹が減ったんだけど
じゃあ食べないことにするぞとかね
お腹が減ってないんだけど
じゃあ食べようとかね
そういうところだけなんですよ
しかし 知る世界もっとあるんです
だからそこら辺はなかなか管理できない
だから我々はもうどうせあの法則によって動くしかないんです
例えば心臓もちゃんと知って動いてるんですよ
でも自分には じゃあ心臓もうちょこっとゆっくり動いてくださいと言ってもやってくれないでしょ
呼吸はそんなもう粗い
粗い呼吸はダメです 丁寧に呼吸しなさいと肺に命令したってもやってくれないんですよ
でもあれは知る機能で管理していますよ
知る機能なんですけど
意識じゃありません 概念のっていうのはそんなすごいちっぽけなもので
概念になってないだけ
だから人間は動物を馬鹿にしているでしょ
頭がないんだ 知識はないんだとかね
虫なんかいくら殺したっても平気やとかね
ミミズとかね まああんなのはもうただの下等生命で
という感じで残酷に生きてますけど
みんなちゃんと知って生きてる生命なんですよ
よくよく考えてみるとね
アサリとかね もう嫉妬も憎しみもないんだからね
もうこちらよりは立派なんですけど
しかしちゃんと知って生きてるんです
だから知る知ると言ったっても
俗世間で言う知るということとまた微妙に違う
この単語しか他の単語もないんですよ
使うためには だから仏教用語は俗世間の話と違うということだけ覚えておいてください
それであの心臓は丁寧に動いているかもしれませんだけど
突然びっくりしちゃったらどうなるんですかね
心臓は  何のことなくのんびりしているところで
いきなり突然びっくりする
その時心臓はどうなるんですかね
いきなり動くでしょ 明らかでしょ
知ることによって変わるんだと
例えば食欲 お腹が空いたというと
それは物理的に言えば肉体に材料は足らない状態
砂糖 やらいろんなもの
さて 肉体が反応している
脳が反応を出しているんだそうとか
化学的なもので変化起きちゃって
これぐらいの品物を入れてくださいと
それが正しければ 物理的な法則だからね
どうにもならないんですよ
自然法則と種の法則だったら
でも自分が例えばこう想像してください
１日も食べてない 忙しくて
それでいっぱいごちそうを作って
一番自分食べたい食べ物ばっかり揃ってもらって
で 食べてやるぞと座る
で よだれも出る もうお腹がすっごく空いてるんだから
1 日も食べてないんだから
もう食べたくてしょうがないんです
それが物理的な法則だったら
この人は当然食べなくちゃいけないんですよ
でないと体が壊れるはずなんです
その瞬間で携帯が鳴る
食べようと思ったところで
携帯が鳴って もしもしと言ったら
あ 実はもう今お母さんもう死んじゃったんだよと
事故があって 即死だよ
あ そう 食べて食べる 今忙しいんだから
後で電話してくださいと言う
あの食欲は瞬時に飛びますよ
もう食べ物を見ただけでも気持ち悪くなる
食べるどころか ショックで倒れちゃう
すぐもう準備して まあ立派な人間だったら
まあ皆様どうかわかりませんだけど
すぐ親のところに飛んでいく
だから 物理法則で説明できるのかと
1 日食べてないことは
当然栄養というものは 1500カロリーを入れない
2500カロリーを入れなくちゃいけないんですよ
でもそれは心が管理するんですよ
食べるっていうことは
心にはそんな余裕は今ないんです
だから 意識無意識は仏教は区別しません
全部知るということにしているんです
ただ 自分の概念で管理できるかできないかということぐらいのことで
例えば自分で考えて心臓を止まったりすることも
早く鼓動させることもできないんだけど
結局はできるんですよ
そういうことになるんです
例えば 年取ってこのもう老けちゃって
しまっちゃって 老化現象あるでしょ
それは自然の流れでしょうと言っても
人の老化現象は様々バラバラでしょ
ぴったし年に合わないんです
1 年でこれぐらい老化してとかね
60 年でこれぐらいとか
それ一定してないんです
あれって何？細胞を生かしているのは心なんですよ
だから汚れた心で 欲やら見やら高慢やらね
あれこれやと希望ばっかり
心にある人は早く老けるんです
早く燃えて年取るんです
すごく穏やかな気分で
もう期待もなく もう穏やかな明るい心でいる場合は
細胞は老化するスピードはすごく遅い
だからそういうのは唯脳論では説明できるはずがないんです
知るということで紡がれ立っています
世界を認識するために
世界をまず感じなくてはならない
そこで心っていうのは知る機能です
知るためには 世界を認識するためには
まず世界を感じる必要があるんです
だから私という物体がこの自覚するために感じるんですよ
体のこと 音が聞くためには
音を感じなくてはならないんですね
したがって感覚が心 または知ることが心という定義になるんです
これでもう定義になったんです
こういう長い過程を経て理解しなきゃわかるものじゃないんです
心って感覚です あるいは知ることです
知るというのは このまあ識ですね
ヴィニャナですね 働きは心
感覚が心ではなく 知る働きは心だと仏教ではさらに分析する
そこで前のスライドで私は定義 2つ出したんです
感覚が心 知ることが心だと
その中で 2つの定義で
仏教は一つチョキンと切ってしまうんです
感覚が心ではなくて 知ることが心だとするんです
それにまたいろいろ訳があるんです
本当は感覚も心なんです
感覚はすべての生命に同じです
なぜかというと 感覚っていうのはどんな生命にも同じですよ
感じるだけだからね 例えば水一滴を感じる
私は水一滴を感じる ミミズも水一滴を感じる
同じですよ  鳥でももう羽の中に水一滴れちゃうと
これ感じるんですよ 知ることで生命は個別化になるんです
しかし ミミズがこの水一滴を感じて何を知るのか
私が水一滴感じて何を知るのかということは違うんです
だから ミミズと私が違うことになるんです
例えば 水に触れると感じるということは
魚にもあるし 私にもありますよ
私も水の中に飛び込んだら水を感じます
水の中にいる魚も水を感じていますよ
しかし 知ることでお互い違うんです
私はこの体中 もう水の中で感じる感覚と魚が感じる感覚からお互い別なものを知っているんです
私はこれ危ないんだと
死んでしまうんだと 上に行かないとと
と恐怖感を感じる 魚は全然へっちゃらで
ああ 何のことないっていう感じでいるんです
感じないわけじゃないんです
どちらでも感じるんだけど
知るところで個別性が生まれるんです
わかりますかね そのポイントは
それで生命が互い違うんですよ
だから感覚が心と言っちゃうとまずいんです
すべての生命は平等で同一ものになっちゃうんです
実際はそうじゃないんです
一個一個の生命は違うものなんです
2人はいません 似ている 2人は
これはどこに現れるかというと
知ることで現れるんです
だから魚も水を感じるし
水に落ちた私も水を感じるんだけど
知る世界が違う ああ 安全しているんだと思ったら
そいつは魚で危ないんだと思ったら
そいつは私で   で 別々になっちゃうんです
だからミミズを水の中に入れちゃうと
ミミズもそれなりに感じるか
聞いたことないんだからわかりません
ミミズは何感じるのかと
まあそれは危ないと感じるでしょう
ミミズも呼吸で空気呼吸してますからね
危ないだろうと感じるかもしれません
しかし ミミズは水の中でもそれなりに呼吸できます
だから私ほど恐怖感は感じないかも
で 私は暇がなくて聞くことできなかったんですけど
皆様このこれでミミズに会ったら聞いてみてください
どう感じるのかと で 推測で言えば
ミミズは皮膚で呼吸するんだから
まあ水の中ででも酸素がありますから
いきなり死ぬということはないんです
と思う でも私は水の中に入っちゃうと
もうかなり早く死んじゃうんですね
だから感じるところではみんな同じですけど
知る世界でそれぞれ変わっていくんです
だからミミズなんかはね
なんだこれ なんかもう軽くて
まあ土がないんだから
下にでも潜って土の中に入ろうかなと思うかもしれませんし
そのより先に魚にパクッと食べられてしまう可能性もあるし
まあどちらかも それでなぜ仏教は知ることが心と定義したわけがそういうわけなんです
一個一個の生命が違うということは説明したいんです
犬も猫も蝶々もミツバチも同じく鳥も私もあの人も同じ花を目で感じるが
花という知識 それぞれ違うんですね
で ミツバチもみんなで同じ花を見る
私もミツバチも蝶々も同じ知識生まれるわけじゃないんです
それぞれ違っていくんです
それから すべてが知ることで始まるんです
なんか聖書の文章みたいですけど
でもはい  今の感覚っていうのがよくわからないんですけれども
例えば  死んでるってことですね
目があるものと目がないものだったら
光の感じ方とか違う  目がなかったら光を感じないでしょ
だからその感覚はすべての生き物に同じっていうのは
私が考えている感覚と説明の角度が違うのかな
だから感覚部品は 5つでしょうに
だから部品があるかないかということでしょう
人間見るでしょ 目がない人は光を感じませんよ
だからその感覚がないだけの話でね
部品そろってるかないかっていうことでね
でも何か感覚なくちゃ生き物じゃないでしょ
アメーバにも感覚あります
目も耳も鼻も何もないでしょ
体だけでしょ でもアメーバもちゃんとした生き物なんです
感覚は 1個しかないんです
我々人間には 5つついてます
本当は6つありますけど
心ももう仏教で入れますからね
六感というね まあ西洋的に言えば五感でしょ
で 五感はそれ五五も揃ってるかいないかっていうぐらいのことで
でも感覚といえば感覚なんですね
うん だから窓口の数が減ってるか
揃ってるかっていうぐらいの差なんです
それで OK ですか うん
たとえ見せ 何て言ったっけ？微細な物質一つでも知ること
自分のことが周りのことですね
するならば それが生命なのです
ちょっと日本語はちょっとおかしいんですけど
まあ以上 自分で訂正してみて読んでください
微細なもうもう 1個の原子 1個かもしれませんよ
原子 1個であろうとも
自分のことを知ってるんだったら生命なんですよ
あるいは周りを知ってるんだったら
もう生命なんですよ あ
これかなり激しく変わってますね
文章を直さないと 知ることの知ることですね
知ることするならば はい
OK です だから生命の定義っていうのは知るということになります
生命の大きさは関係ないんですよ
これはいい加減な話ですけど
あの原子 1個の生命はいませんだけど
あの でもまあ仏教は素粒子の話だからね
素粒子だけで成り立っている生命はあり得る
この神々とか言っているのはそういう連中なんです
原子は持ってないんです
素粒子ぐらいの体で だから寿命長いんですよ
肉体はすぐ壊れますけど
原子はそう簡単に壊れないでしょ？鉄とか酸素とかはね
かなり長持ちする で 原子の中でも安定した原子は結構
あの まああの窒素でしたっけ？窒素でしたっけ
そういうものはかなり安定していて
なかなか変化起きないとかね
まあだからあの肉体はすぐ壊れますけど
原子だって元素ですね
元素はそう簡単には壊れませんということになる
素粒子になってくると
むちゃ寿命は長いんです
だから神々の寿命は長いんです
心臓はないんだからね
心臓発作を起こすはずもないし
脳がないんだから あの痴呆にはなるはずはないんです
しかし 体はちゃんと持っている
体の構造は違う まあ何でできてるかわかりませんだけど
我々は三次元の物質論でしか語ることできませんだからね
全て三次元というわけでもないんです
それでまあ定義的に言いたい
言いたいのは 幻想一向でも無私知るということするんだったら生命であること
この知る機能は心なのです
しかし 正しくありのままに知るのではなく
自分の主観で知るんです
それで問題はそこから始まるんですよ
知ることが生命なんですけど
この生命はありのままに正しく知ろうとしないんです
自分勝手に知るんです
だから 私が見る花と蝶々が見る花が違っていくんですよ
同じ花見ているのに 同じ水に
例えば誰かがかなりのあの水槽というか
すごい深い水槽があって
誰かが魚 1匹とワニ捕まって
ボーンと水に放り投げちゃうと
二人とも水を感じますよ
でも二人の知る世界が違うんです
魚は舞い上がって喜んでいて
あ やっと命が守ったと
私がこれだったら殺されそうと
いうことで 知る世界はもう主観的になるんです
人はご飯がおいしいと知る
牛は草がおいしいと知る
それぞれ違うんですよ
人ならご飯を見て あ おいしいと知るんです
牛は草を見て あ おいしいものをやって知るんです
それで入れ替えちゃうとおいしくないんです
私の前に草を置いて 牛の前でご飯を置いちゃうと
もうお互いもうなんだこれまずいと
食えるものじゃないと思っちゃうんです
だから問題は草はまずいんですかね
食えるものじゃないんですかね
ということなんです 草って何やと
牛に対しては美味しいものかもしれませんだけど
人間にとってはそうじゃない
それで同じ草はライオンに出したらどう見るのかと
ライオンはもしかするとこの上で体はぐにゃぐにゃした方が虫が落ちて便利だなと思うかもしれません
だからといって 私は草の上で体がぐにゃぐにゃしたくない
もうもう痒くなるんだそうと
それで草の中に住んでいる虫たちはまた別な考え方で
で 鳥がそれを見て あ これ持っていけばすぐ食れるぞと思うかもしれませんし
一体全体草って何や？という答えがなくなっちゃうんですよ
それぞれ自分のことしか知らないんだから
だから ありのままに知るならば真理であるはずなんですよ
例えば地球が丸いということは真理でしょうし
もう人が知っても知らなくても
丸いことは丸いに決まっている
だから美味しいものって何やと聞いたら答えは無数でしょ
聞く生命が 違う違う言葉を言うんです
それで仏教ではこの神々の存在も説明していますけど
神々はいろんな次元があります
すごい複数なんですけど
あのものを食べない ほとんど食べないんです
食べないんだけど なんか食べてるような感じのレベルもあります
しかし 私たちとは違うんです
別に口とかお腹とかあるわけじゃないんです
だから この周りのそのある波動をずっと吸収するだけで
そこで自分の体を維持する
その中で物質的な波動を受ける神々もいて
そうでない精神的なもので生き続けるものもいます
一つはこのピーチバッガーという神々がいるんですよ
ピーチっていうのは喜び
バッガーっていうのは食うということで食する喜びを食する
喜びを食べるってどういうことですかね
さっぱりわからないでしょう
ディナーに喜びを食べてるんだと
これ 箸で食べたいでしょうかね
ナイフでフォークで食べるでしょうかね
だからもう我々にはわからないんだけど
その喜びを食べる神々っていうのは
この肉体という肉体はまあ当然ないんだけど
この体がね すごい微妙なもので
心によって維持しているんですよ
それで心に常に喜びがないと体が維持できないんです
だから そういう展開に生まれた神々はずーっと喜んでいるんですよ
ちょこっと間違って喜びが消えちゃうと死んでるんです
大変です 我々も 24時間栄養を取ってますよ
もし細胞がストやっちゃうと終わり
ならまあ細胞にお願いしておいてください
ストでもやってはいけませんと
やっちゃうともう終わりですよ
ですから 美味しいって何やと質問を出されると
あの喜びという気持ちで維持している神々は
美味しいといえばリンゴも美味しいとか思わないでしょう
まあ大体リンゴを見えませんしね
そういうそっちの人々には
牛に聞けばまあ草でしょうし
人間に聞けばそれぞれバラバラでしょ
人間もみんな同じくご飯美味しいとは言わないでしょうに
ライオンは別 虎に聞けば別な答え
ミミズに聞けば まあ腐ってる土でしょうしね
腐ってる葉っぱとかね
これまた腐ってないと栄養になりませんよ
ただ枯れ葉食べませんよ
あのミミズは でも それぞれの生命にそうやって美味しいってことになります
だから我々の知る世界っていうのは
明らかに私だけの世界で主観ですよ
ありのままのことというのは
知ることはあり得なくなっているんです
心が良いと判断したものを得ようとする
守ろうとする それに執着をする
次のステップ 自分の心が良いと判断したものはもう得ようとするんですね
牛も草食たら とにかくもうとにかくそちらそちらに行くんですよ
守ろうとする それに執着もする
悪いと判断したものから離れようとする
それを壊そう 攻撃しようとする
それに怒りを抱く これが牛でもミミズでも誰でもやっています
善し悪しの判断しないものに対して無関心を抱く
無知という知です それが無知といったら知がないという意味でしょ
でも無知っていうのも知なんです
知ることなんです ヴィンヤーナなんです
何か 良いと知るものを得ることが楽しみ
幸福で それらを得られないことと
悪いと知るものが得ることは苦しみ
不幸なのです もう全部厳密に定義ありますよ
もう 自分の心で良いと知ったものがあるんだったら幸福です
ないんだったら不幸なんです
世間の幸福 不幸には定めた意味はありません
だから幸福って何でしょうかというふうな聞いても定めた意味がないんです
そのその生命によって違うんです
その生命が良しと判断したものがあることが幸福で
悪いと判断したものはあることが不幸なんです
それで人間のおかしいところは
もう定義もないのに 理解してというのはね
よくそういう単語を使うんです
個が良いと知ることによって決めるものです
幸福 不幸っていうのは
その個が個人が決めたものによりけり
生命の生き方は知ることによって左右されるのです
例えば ある一人一人人間があの生でサツマイモを食べることが最高に美味しいやと決めてしまっちゃえばどうなるんですかね
その人の人生はそれで変わります
それからもう生のサツマイモばっかり探してるんだから
あるいはもう刺身とかはもうもう美味しいんだけど
もう死んで時間経ったものは嫌やと
生きたままで食べた方が一番新鮮で美味しいんじゃないかなと思っちゃうと
その人は生きているものはそのまま食べることになっちゃうんです
だから我々の人生っていうのは
自分が何が良しと判断したか
何が悪いと判断したかということによって生き方が変わっていくんです
それは生命の生き方なんです
だから強盗は職業としてそれが良しと判断していますよ
それで強盗になっちゃうんです
不倫することはなんて幸せ
楽しいんだ 生きてるかいだ気がしますよと思っちゃうと
もう一生懸命不倫しちゃうんです
えーと賭け事はもう耐えられ
たまらん ないんだと楽しくてと思ったら
もうそちらに依存しちゃうんです
それで知るというのは知識ですかね
知識とは 知った情報を他の情報や感情
判断などで掛け合わせて合成した現象です
知識っていうのは合成したものなんです
知ることは知識ではありません
だからミミズにも知ることはあるんだけど
知識はありませんね 合成しないんだから
例えば我々 私はバラの花を見て
これはなんとかなんとかの名前のバラの花ですと思っちゃうと
いろんな過去の知識で一緒に合成してるでしょ
それが知識なんです アメーバにも知るはあるが
知識はないでしょう ないでしょうというのは聞いたことはないんだからね
ないと思う 知も知識もあるのままの真理ではありません
それで問題は 知識は当然ありのままのものじゃないんです
すべて合成したもの この知識に引っかかっているのは人間だけなんです
だから人間がすっごく生きる上で失敗する
犬は失敗しない 猫も失敗しない
聞いたことはある 失敗した犬とか
子育てに失敗しまったとか
ないんです 食べるものが当たったとか
自然に知るだけだからね
牛でもね まあいろんな葉っぱ食べますけど
ある葉っぱはきしんと避けますよ
知る世界ではもうそんなに失敗ないんだけど
知識になってくると人間はキノコ食べるんだけど
毒キノコと食用きのこの区別できんだから
猿はものすごい見事に子育てするんだけど
人間は見事に失敗する
それは知識のせいなんです
そこで私は仏教の立場から言うのは
まあ知識は間違っているのは当たり前なんですけど
知ることさえも間違いですと
ありのままの事実じゃありませんと
このまたはグループの主観です
知識っていうのは 知識っていうのは私の主観で
私が合成したもの あるいはグループ知識もあります
だから人間というグループは自分たちだけの知識を持ってます
犬たちは自分たちだけのそれなりの知識を持ってます
猿は猿たちでということで
それから日本人のグループと中国人のグループだったら
それぞれ知識また違うんです
アメリカ人のグループとヨーロッパ人のグループと行っちゃうと
またそれぞれ知識違います
だからグループの主観も知識なんです
なぜならば グループの場合はアイディアを交換しないとね
成り立ちませんだから知識の開発
知の合成ですね 楽に生きるために必要とするレベルで止まります
それでよく我々は知識の開発ということを言っているでしょうね
あまり意味がないんですよ
楽に生きるところです
それで人間 あらゆることを研究したり発見したり
なんでしているのかというと
それで儲かるんだからなんです
それで EMS 細胞でしたっけ？あの細胞はステムセルはステムセルの培養できたと
もう発表しちゃって それで自分がノーベル賞を取れるそうとも思ったでしょうね
これで無茶金儲かるんだぞとかね
後であれは捏造したんだと
だから真面目に科学者を信じてください
まあとにかく あの 我々の知識っていうのは
楽に生きるために 楽に儲かって贅沢して生きるための程度でストップするんです
犬にもカラスにも このあまりまあ冗談で書いたんですけど
犬にもカラスにも知識はあります
いくらか上の動物たちだから
犬にもカラスにも知識がありますよ
しかし 算数は知りませんね
犬もカラスも算数は知りませんし
歴史にも興味を持てない
来年は平成 18年だとも知らない
それは人間の知識なんですよ
なぜかというと それを知ることは人間にとっては役に立ちますが
カラスにも犬にも役に立ちませんね
だから犬は犬に楽に生きるぐらいの知識開発しますよ
例えば どうすればこのアホな飼い主に愛されるのかとかね
玄関開けると飛んでいったら
あいつはバカだから喜びそうと
バーンといったら死んだふりしちゃうと
まあ死んだふりじゃなくて転がっちゃえばいいと
これでこのバカが喜びますよと
これちゃんとやるんですよ
それ以外は やりません
だから犬を調教したっても
ある範囲で止まりますよ
犬にとって必要なものがありますよ
可愛がってくれることと餌をくれること
それ以外じゃやらせてみてください
何一つもできない だから人間も同じなんですよ
あれは犬だからとか 人間も同じことでご褒美ないと知識は開発しないんです
どうってことないんです
だから知識っていうのはそんなにすごいことでもないんだ
ただまあ必要なレベルでストップするもんですよ
はい それで一旦休憩いたします
とか復活しました  復活祭はもう
子供